let's go out to toledo ohio have a
conversation with charles
charles good afternoon how can ken and i
help
hey thanks for taking my phone call so
um
got married in in 17 uh 2017.
we have we do have joint accounts all of
our accounts are
our joint accounts both on both um
we got married well
the question is i'm wondering if i that
let her
finish paying off her car or if i should
just
do it myself because i'm getting tired
of having it now to explain that you
know after saying we have joined
accounts
yeah when we got married the agreement
was she was going to stay home
and and do some couponing about time we
got married
i started couponing and i really fell in
love with couponing i i
loved it i i felt like i was stealing
from the stores you know they were
paying me to carry their stuff out of
the stores
so i told her you know i said i make
pretty decent money 28 dollars an hour i
said uh you know and i can work all the
hours i want i work
pretty much 60 hours right now sometimes
one more a week
um i said i'll make the money you stay
home and save us money
take care of the kids take care of the
house you know go to the gym etc
none of that really happened very well
and i finally assumed okay maybe she
just
can't coupon well she has a hard time
looking at two products and only which
one's the better
deal um you know so
she ended up getting a part-time job 13
an hour which is about all she's ever
done
as retail stuff and so i'm trying to
encourage her
to because i know when i paid off my car
when i had a loan before for my car i
paid it off and that felt great
so i told her i said okay when you get
your paycheck every other friday
you know take out what you want for you
you're spending money and then put the
rest on the car
yeah and she's been plinking away at it
about
uh four or five maybe six hundred
dollars every two weeks and
it's it's like trying to shoot a bear
with it's okay hold on all right
all right all right charles charles okay
i tried
i appreciate what you're saying yeah
something's not lining up so if you two
are on joint accounts
that means you guys are making your
money decisions together
then you shouldn't be calling us asking
us if you should pay off your wife's car
and then you tell us a story that she's
not paying enough out of her
13 hour job if you've got the money to
pay it off pay it off why do you need
my permission or ao's permission and you
certainly don't need her permission
other than buy-in to say this is our
money
but you're you're saying you have joint
accounts but you're acting as though you
have two separate
uh accounts and and she's just kind of
paid it off
whenever she wants to if you want the
car to be paid off sit down with her and
cast vision
and say we're gonna pay it off i i don't
know what's missing here
the only thing i left out and i
apologize for leaving this out is
i wanted her to feel good about paying
it off so maybe
she could do what i did which is like
wow i paid that off
i need to go make more money no it's not
working charlie prove
my life charles she's not wired the way
you're wired you're mr coupon guy
not her yeah and here's the problem that
i keep hearing
charles and and and i i'm not married so
i
you know i told the producer james the
other day i'm gonna be careful how i say
things because i'm not married all right
set me up and then i'll hit it i'm gonna
set you up all right uh
they can't be divided i ca i keep
hearing her car
her money her this and it's not a we
it's not a
are we gonna do this is not our account
it's her money
this that i feel separation within a
marriage yeah
is this the only debt you have
it is it's doing well other than the
house mortgage and i was just hoping it
might be encouraging
no stop charles charles charles we've
already gone down this path
you're treating her like she's your
teenage daughter i can't wait to get
married dude
how much is the car how much is how much
is owed on the car
700 bucks that's been killing me for the
last time oh my gosh i'm hanging up the
phone it's the first time i'm gonna hang
up on somebody yeah hang it up i can't
do it yeah i can't do it no more
this is ridiculous charles this is
ridiculous pay the car off today oh my
gosh
i've never ever hung up on anybody
what's going
on this just happened he said
i thought he was going to say like 8 000
i'm trying to get my wife to pay off the
car with her 13
an hour job 700 i wanted to feel good
pay the car off
oh i didn't say nothing but listen
there's
i'm not even see i'm sorry james i'm not
even asking my wife i'm just cutting the
check
i'm just gonna cut the check baby i paid
off your card um
you know what i do i would i'd spend 750
tonight
700 to pay the car off 50 on flowers and
tell her what you did
come on what is happening here she's
clearly not interested in paying it off
we got a communication problem on top of
all this oh
my goodness what a good guy but now
charles listen you're a good man
your heart's in the right place i think
your brain is totally
in a different place you all need to get
back on the same page
and say i'm making this decision for us
this isn't about having your wife feel
good about herself
get rid of the 700 get out of debt this
guy
he wants to yeah he knows how and you
know what as a matter of fact i would
suggest that you too
you two together go listen to one of our
uh teammates here
john delonay y'all need some counseling
together you all need to talk through
this
together because uh there's no way in
the world i'm having this kind of
conversation
with my wife i'm just being honest i'm
sorry if i offend anyone but
i'm not babe i paid off the cop god
bless you i love you
here's some roses this is the ramsay
show